MISSION CONTROL: MARS TEAM,
MARS TEAM, BE ADVISED,
STAY AT YOUR CONSOLES.
T-MINUS 10 SECONDS.
HANA SEUNG: CAN I
ASK YOU A QUESTION?
ASTRONAUT: OF
COURSE, GO AHEAD.
HANA SEUNG: DO
YOU EVER MISS HOME?
MAN: THREE, TWO, ONE.
LILY SEUNG: HANA,
COME ON, LET'S GO.
COME ON, JOON.
JOON SEUNG: THANKS.
♪ ♪
LILY SEUNG: ALMOST
AT THE NEW HOUSE, GUYS.
HOME SWEET HOME.
COME ON, GIRLS.
JOON, THAT ONE GOES
WITH ME INTO THE KITCHEN.
HANA, TAKE THAT
UPSTAIRS INTO YOUR ROOM.
♪ ♪
JOON SEUNG:
UM, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
HANA SEUNG: I WANNA
SEE WHAT'S UP THERE,
PASS ME THAT BOX.
JOON SEUNG: NO WAY.
IT SMELLS LIKE
OLD PEOPLE UP HERE.
CARLY ONCE SAID SHE FOUND
A DEAD BODY IN AN ATTIC.
HANA SEUNG: REALLY?
JOON SEUNG: THAT'S
WHAT SHE TOLD ME.
♪ ♪
[STATIC AND HISS]
WHAT'S THAT?
SO IT SAYS HERE THAT
THESE ARE FREQUENCIES.
IT ALSO SAYS HERE
IT'S ILLEGAL TO OPERATE
A HAM RADIO
WITHOUT A LICENSE.
ASTRONAUT: THIS
IS NOVEMBER, ALPHA,
THIS IS NOVEMBER,
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA.
DO YOU COPY?
HANA SEUNG: I SAW
THAT WRITTEN IN HERE.
HELLO?
ASTRONAUT: MISSION CONTROL.
[STATIC INTERFERENCE]
HANA SEUNG: HELLO?
[INAUDIBLE RADIO CHATTER].
HANA SEUNG: ARE YOU OKAY?
HANA SEUNG: IT'LL
PROBABLY WORK BETTER OUTSIDE.
NOVEMBER, ALPHA,
ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA.
HELLO?
RADIO ANNOUNCER: THERE'S
A CHANCE IT WILL RAIN TODAY,
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THEN ON SUNDAY...
[INAUDIBLE].
LILY SEUNG: HANA,
ARE YOU READY TO GO?
[INAUDIBLE
RADIO ANNOUNCER]
JOON, HURRY UP,
WE'RE GONNA BE LATE!
[OVERLAPPING
GROUP CHATTER]
JOON SEUNG: WE HAVE TO
GET RID OF THESE LUNCHES,
THEY SMELL
HORRIBLE TO OTHER PEOPLE.
HANA SEUNG: BUT I'M HUNGRY.
MICHELLE:
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY,
I SHOULDN'T BE LAUGHING.
IT WAS SO FUNNY.
JOON SEUNG: LET'S GO
SIT WITH THOSE GIRLS.
HANA SEUNG: I DON'T KNOW.
JOON SEUNG: COME ON,
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
HANA SEUNG: YOU GO AHEAD.
JOON SEUNG:
FINE, WISH ME LUCK.
CHRISTINE:
SHE'LL HAVE FRIENDS.
LIKE, ONE ISN'T
GOING TO RUIN YOUR LIFE.
JOON SEUNG: HI,
I'M JOON, I'M NEW HERE.
CHRISTINE: I'M CHRISTINE.
JOON SEUNG: DID
YOU SEE MR. K TODAY?
HANA SEUNG: YEAH.
JOON SEUNG: I
THINK HE HAS A WIG.
HANA SEUNG: REALLY?
I DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE.
JOON SEUNG: SO, THAT GIRL
CHRISTINE INVITED ME OVER,
DO YOU WANNA COME?
HANA SEUNG:
MAYBE NEXT TIME.
JOON SEUNG: OKAY,
WELL, TELL MOM I'LL
BE HOME BEFORE DINNER.
YOU KNOW HOW SHE GETS.
♪ ♪
RADIO ANNOUNCER: AND
THERE'S A SERIES OF HIGH SPEEDS.
MAN: HEY, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING WITH MY TRUCK?
HANA SEUNG: UH,
NOTHING, SORRY.
♪ ♪
DANIELLE: HEY,
YOU ALL RIGHT?
WHY ARE YOU SITTING
OUT HERE WITH THE TRASH?
HANA SEUNG: UH, NO REASON.
DANIELLE: WELL, YOU HUNGRY?
CARL, HOW MANY TIMES
DO I HAVE TO TELL YOU?
YOU CAN'T KEEP YOUR
DENTURES ON THE TABLE.
CARL: IT'S ONLY SOUP.
DANIELLE: IT'S COMMON SENSE.
ALBERT: PRETTY
EXCITING STUFF, AIN'T IT?
I STILL REMEMBER
WHEN THEY LAUNCHED A
MONKEY INTO SPACE, 1948.
HE WAS CATAPULTED
INTO THAT BLACK ABYSS THAT
FLOATS OVER US,
AND HE NEVER CAME BACK.
DANIELLE: HERE, DAD,
DON'T FORGET TO TAKE THESE.
ALBERT: BUT IN THAT MOMENT,
THE LITTLE CHIMP BECAME A
SPACE PIONEER FOR
FUTURE MONKEYS LIKE US.
DANIELLE: IGNORE HIM.
ALBERT: PANCAKES ARE
THE SECRET FOR A LONG LIFE.
HANA SEUNG: MY MOM
SAYS GINSENG IS.
ALBERT: DOESN'T SOUND
AS DELICIOUS AS PANCAKES.
HANA SEUNG: SHE SAYS
IT CURES EVERYTHING FROM
COLDS TO HEARTBREAK.
[STATIC]
ALBERT: WHAT'S THAT?
HANA SEUNG: OH, IT'S
JUST THIS OLD RADIO I FOUND.
ALBERT: I HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS MODEL FOR AGES.
HANA SEUNG: YOU KNOW
ABOUT THESE THINGS?
ALBERT: KNOW ABOUT
THESE THINGS?
I'M OLD, OF COURSE I
KNOW ABOUT THESE THINGS.
HANA SEUNG: OH, AND
THERE'S THIS NOTEBOOK WITH
ALL THESE CODES IN IT.
THERE'S THIS ONE I
HEARD ON THE RADIO.
NOVEMBER, ALPHA, ONE.
ALBERT: SIERRA, SIERRA.
HANA SEUNG: YEAH,
HOW DID YOU KNOW?
ALBERT: WELL, YOU WERE
TALKING TO THAT BLACK ABYSS
THAT THE
MONKEY HAD LEAD US TO.
HANA SEUNG: SPACE?
ALBERT: SPACE.
HANA SEUNG: I'M NOT
SURE IF THIS IS WORKING.
ALBERT: THE NEW ANTENNA
SHOULD BE HELPING, DO IT AGAIN.
HANA SEUNG: NOVEMBER,
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA,
DO YOU COPY?
CHRISTINE: DANIEL
LOOKS LIKE JACK.
HE'S BLONDE AND HE HAS,
I THINK HE HAS BLUE EYES.
HANA SEUNG: NOVEMBER,
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA.
CHRISTINE: BUT HE'S
CUTER AND THEY'RE BROTHERS.
HANA SEUNG: MAYBE WE
CALCULATE THE TIME OF DAY WRONG.
CHRISTINE: WHAT
IS SHE DOING NOW?
JOON SEUNG: UM,
I'M NOT ACTUALLY SURE.
HANA SEUNG: NOVEMBER,
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA,
DO YOU COPY?
MADISON: I THINK
SHE MADE CONTACT.
THAT PICTURE IS AWESOME.
CHRISTINE: SEND IT TO ME.
HANA SEUNG: NOVEMBER
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA.
♪ ♪
LILY SEUNG: JOON,
JOON, WHERE WERE YOU?
JOON SEUNG: OUT.
LILY SEUNG: WHAT DO
YOU MEAN OUT, WITH WHO?
JOON SEUNG:
IT'S FRIDAY NIGHT.
LILY SEUNG:
WERE YOU SMOKING?
JOON SEUNG: NO.
LILY SEUNG: YOU
REEK OF CIGARETTES.
JOON SEUNG: MOM.
LILY SEUNG:
DINNER'S READY.
♪ ♪
ALBERT: HELLO THERE.
SO I HAVE THIS NEW
ANTENNA DESIGN WE CAN TRY.
THAT WAS THE
DAYTON HAMVENTION, 1997.
THAT WAS A GOOD YEAR.
HANA SEUNG: UM, I'VE
BEEN THINKING, AND,
YOU SHOULD HAVE THIS.
ALBERT: WELL, I
HAVE ONE ALREADY.
HANA SEUNG: I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT HERE THEN.
I'M BECOMING THE
WEIRD KID AT SCHOOL.
ALBERT: YOU KNOW
WHO WAS WEIRD?
EINSTEIN WAS WEIRD,
PICASSO, MOZART.
A BUNCH OF WEIRDOS!
YOU KNOW, YOU REMIND
ME A LOT OF MY DAUGHTER
WHEN SHE WAS YOUR AGE.
YOU MAY NOT SEE IT NOW, BUT
ONE DAY, WHEN YOU LOOK BACK,
YOU'LL BE
GRATEFUL FOR BEING WEIRD.
LET'S TRY
THIS NEW ANTENNA.
HANA SEUNG: SO IF I GO
TO A MORE OPEN CLEARING,
I CAN GET A
BETTER CONNECTION?
ALBERT: EXACTLY, THE
TREES AND BUILDINGS AROUND
HERE ARE
OBSTRUCTING THE SIGNAL
AS THE INTERNATIONAL
SPACE STATION PASSES BY.
THERE'S ONLY A SHORT WINDOW
OF TIME TO MAKE THE CONNECTION.
HANA SEUNG: 7:03 P.M.,
POINTING UPWARD,
FOLLOWING A
NORTHEASTERN PATH.
ALBERT: THERE.
LET ME TRY IT.
HANA SEUNG: WHY ARE
YOU HITTING IT LIKE THAT?
ALBERT: BACK IN THE DAY,
WHEN OUR ELECTRONICS
MALFUNCTIONED,
WE GIVE 'EM A GOOD
OLD FASHION WHACK.
RADIO ANNOUNCER:
PARTLY SUNNY,
TEMPERATURE, 86,
MOSTLY SUNNY SKIES.
TEMPERATURE, 82.
WINDS SOUTH AT
FIVE MILES AN HOUR.
TEMPERATURE, 86.
HANA SEUNG: WHAT WOULD YOU
ASK THE ASTRONAUTS ON THE ISS?
ALBERT: I THINK I'D ASK THEM
HOW IT LOOKS FROM OUT THERE.
IN THE GREAT
FRAMEWORK OF THINGS,
A LIFE IS ONLY A
FRACTION OF A SECOND.
IN A UNIVERSE, THAT'S
ALMOST 14 BILLION YEARS OLD.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
SOMEONE OUTSIDE OF EVERYTHING.
GIRL: OH, MY GOSH.
ALBERT: SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS WHAT REALLY MATTERS.
LILY SEUNG: HI KATIE,
I'M LILY, NICE TO MEET YOU.
KATIE: NICE TO MEET YOU.
LILY SEUNG: I'VE LEFT
A LIST OF PHONE NUMBERS AND
EMERGENCY
CONTACTS BESIDE THE TV.
AND HERE IS MONEY
FOR PIZZA TONIGHT.
WHERE ARE MY KEYS?
KATIE: LET ME GUESS,
YOU MUST BE JOON?
HANA SEUNG: HANA.
KATIE: DARN, WELL,
I HAD A 50% CHANCE.
LILY SEUNG: JOON IS
WORKING ON A SCIENCE PROJECT
UNTIL ABOUT 5:00 TONIGHT.
CALL ME IF YOU NEED ANYTHING.
HANA, I'M WORKING A
DOUBLE TONIGHT ON THE BASE.
I'LL BE HOME
IN THE MORNING.
YOU GIRLS BE
GOOD, ALL RIGHT?
MADISON: I WONDER HOW MANY
ANIMALS DIED TO MAKE THIS COAT?
CHRISTINE: OH, MY GOODNESS.
PICTURE, TWO.
MADISON: ALL RIGHT,
LET ME SEE HOW IT LOOKS.
CHRISTINE: OKAY, #HOTSTUFF.
MADISON: YEAH, I KNOW.
JOON SEUNG: I WISH MY MOM
WOULD LET ME GET A CELLPHONE.
CHRISTINE: YEAH, MY
MOM'S ALL RIGHT LIKE THAT,
BUT SHE CHECKS
IT, LIKE, EVERY DAY,
SO I HAVE TO
DELETE EVERYTHING.
MADISON: YOU
DON'T HAVE A PHONE?
JOON SEUNG: NO.
MADISON: THAT SUCKS.
CHRISTINE: YEAH, IT DOES.
JOON SEUNG: HANA
WOULD LOVE THIS.
CHRISTINE: OH, MY GOD.
YOU LOOK EXACTLY
LIKE YOUR SISTER.
MADISON: I WOULD
PUT THAT DOWN.
CHRISTINE:
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
MADISON: SUPER CUTE,
I WOULD GET IT.
CHRISTINE: IT'S $18.
MADISON: YOU
CAN'T AFFORD THAT.
JOON SEUNG: WHAT
ARE YOU DOING?
CHRISTINE: WHAT?
IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
IT'S JUST A SHIRT, BESIDES,
I CAN TOTALLY OUTRUN THAT GUY.
MADISON: IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
WE DO IT ALL THE TIME.
CASHIER: YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SECURITY CAMERAS
EVERYWHERE, RIGHT?
CHRISTINE: GO, GO, GO, GO.
MADISON: COME ON.
[CARS PASSING]
♪ ♪
KATIE: OH, HEY,
YOU MUST BE JOON.
JOON SEUNG: YEAH.
KATIE: I'M KATIE,
YOUR BABYSITTER.
HANA IS UPSTAIRS
IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW.
JOON SEUNG: THANKS.
KATIE: GREAT.
JOON SEUNG: HANA?
♪ ♪
HANA SEUNG:
ALBERT, DO YOU COPY?
ALBERT: HANA?
HANA SEUNG: IT'S HANA, WILL
YOU BE BY YOUR RADIO TONIGHT?
ALBERT: OF COURSE, OVER.
HANA SEUNG: OVER AND OUT.
JOON SEUNG: HELLO?
HANA SEUNG: JOON?
JOON SEUNG: HANA?
HANA SEUNG: WHERE DID
YOU GET A HAM RADIO?
JOON SEUNG: I FOUND
ONE AT A THRIFT STORE.
IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR YOU.
WHERE ARE YOU ANYWAY?
HANA SEUNG: I'M TRYING TO
GET A BETTER SIGNAL SO I'M
GOING TO THE
TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN.
JOON SEUNG: UM, WHY?
HANA SEUNG: THERE'S
JUST SOMEONE I REALLY
HAVE TO TALK TO.
JOON SEUNG: HOW CAN I HELP?
DO YOU SEE A
TELEPHONE POLE NEAR YOU?
HANA SEUNG: YEAH.
JOON SEUNG: THERE SHOULD BE
A HIKING PATH THAT STARTS THERE.
HANA SEUNG: I FOUND IT.
♪ ♪
[THUNDER]
JOON SEUNG: HANA?
KATIE: DID YOU HEAR
HOW LOUD THAT THUNDER WAS?
I MEAN, WHERE'S HANA?
JOON SEUNG: UH,
SHE'S NOT FEELING WELL.
SHE'S BEEN IN THE
BATHROOM FOR A WHILE.
KATIE: ALL RIGHT,
I HADN'T SEEN HER FOR A
LITTLE BIT SO GOT
A LITTLE WORRIED.
HELLO?
YEAH, NO, NO.
WE HAVEN'T
LOST POWER YET.
JOON SEUNG:
HANA, ARE YOU THERE?
[GUSTING WIND]
[HARD RAIN]
ALBERT: HANA?
JOON SEUNG:
HANA, ARE YOU THERE?
KATIE: ALRIGHT, JIG'S UP.
I KNOW ONE
OF YOU ISN'T HERE.
JOON SEUNG: SHE'S
IN THE BASEMENT.
KATIE: I'M
CALLING YOUR MOTHER.
[THUNDER]
[HARD RAIN]
♪ ♪
HANA SEUNG: COME ON!
ALBERT?
JOON?
HELLO?
♪ ♪
[HARD RAIN]
KATIE: YOUR MOM'S
GONNA KILL ME.
HOW DO YOU LOSE A KID?
LILY SEUNG: JOON,
WHERE'S YOUR SISTER?
♪ ♪
REALLY JOON, WHY
UP THE MOUNTAIN?
JOON SEUNG: SHE WANTED TO
GET A BETTER CONNECTION.
TO TALK TO
THE SPACE STATION.
LILY SEUNG: WHY
THE SPACE STATION?
JOON SEUNG:
TURN LEFT UP HERE.
♪ ♪
HANA SEUNG: ALBERT?
ALBERT: HANA,
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
HANA SEUNG: A LITTLE
SOAKED FROM THE STORM,
BUT I'M ALL RIGHT.
GO TO FREQUENCY 144.49.
JOON, DO YOU COPY?
HELLO?
JOON, ARE YOU THERE?
JOON SEUNG: HANA?
I'M HERE WITH MOM.
LILY SEUNG: HANA?
YOU'RE GROUNDED FOR
THE REST OF THE YEAR.
HANA SEUNG: I KNOW.
MOM, I GOTTA GO.
AND I PROMISE I'LL
GET HOME SOON.
JUST TUNE INTO
FREQUENCY 144.49, OKAY?
NOVEMBER, ALPHA, ONE,
SIERRA, SIERRA, DO YOU COPY?
ASTRONAUT: THIS IS NOVEMBER,
ALPHA, ONE, SIERRA, SIERRA.
WE HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR ABOARD THE
INTERNATIONAL
SPACE STATION, OVER.
HANA SEUNG: HI,
THIS IS HANA SEUNG.
CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
ASTRONAUT:
OF COURSE, GO AHEAD.
HANA SEUNG: WHAT DOES
THE EARTH LOOK LIKE FROM
WAY UP THERE?
ASTRONAUT: IT'S
BRIGHT AND COLORFUL.
HOPEFUL.
IT LOOKS LIKE HOME.
HANA SEUNG: DO
YOU EVER MISS HOME?
ASTRONAUT: I DO,
I THINK ABOUT IT A LOT.
AS A KID, I REALLY
STRUGGLED TO FIND WHERE
I FIT IN THE WORLD.
HANA SEUNG: I FEEL
LIKE THAT SOMETIMES, TOO.
ASTRONAUT: FOR ME, I JUST
HAD TO CHANGE MY PERSPECTIVE.
AND NOW, WHENEVER I
THINK OF THE WORD HOME,
I DON'T THINK OF A PLACE.
I THINK OF MY FAMILY.
OF MY MOTHER, OF MY SISTER.
IT TOOK ME YEARS TO
REALIZE THAT A HOME CAN
CHANGE OVER TIME, THAT
IT ISN'T A DESTINATION
OR A LOCATION.
MISSION CONTROL:
T-MINUS TEN SECONDS.
ASTRONAUT: AND ONCE
YOU FIND THAT PLACE,
HOME IS ANYWHERE
YOU MAKE IT.
MISSION CONTROL: 3, 2, 1...
ANNOUNCER: NOW THAT YOU
KNOW HOW THEIR STORY BEGINS,
JOIN HANNA AND JOON ON
THEIR HISTORIC MISSION TO
MAKE MARS HOME.
JOON: I'M LOOKING
AT A RED PLANET.
ELON MUSK: IT'LL BE THE
GREATEST ADVENTURE EVER.
ANNOUNCER: "MARS" A
GLOBAL EVENT SERIES,
MONDAYS AT 9:00PM,
STARTING NOVEMBER, 14.
ON NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC.
♪ [MUSIC PLAYS
THROUGH CREDITS] ♪